the Joe Rogan experience I go to these
TED conferences every year and I was
lighter I feel like I was treated like a
leper you know and I went to Ted you
know and the organ was never Ted was so
afraid of him talk about psychedelic
mushroom how many years ago this into
2008 when I first went Mike what's it
like now though there's right this last
time I mean I was treated like a super
celebrity I had these hugely hugely
powerful people some of the names you
probably know who came up to me and
would shake my shoulders going now I
understand now I understand
down boy you know there did but they
woken to something and they're their
mates their friends their business
associates you know there seemed that
the common theme is wow he was such a
jerk before and he's so nice now yeah
the seeking cooperation and they still
are productive they're still are
creative they're banging it out the
coders in in Silicon Valley know that
micro dosing helps their coding ability
so it's a competitive advantage to those
other computer companies that do not hmm
you know I think any any new business
populated in particular by young people
who are not doing micro dosing are gonna
be a competitive disadvantage mmm
because the creativity flow the
camaraderie the community seeking to
benefit the Commons and also reward
yourself I'm not saying it's all you
know just just helping help in the
Commons but the idea of being able to
reward yourself and people rejoice and
your success and they benefit from it as
well it really integrates people
together yeah it's also people need to
understand that there's a lot of this
squirreling away resources and money and
things and and trying to climb that
corporate ladder this is a finite life
it doesn't last that long it's a trick
you get sucked into this trick and this
trick is what every CEO and every head
of every corporation every chief
financial officer all these people that
are just trying to like improve the
bottom line rake in more money keep this
company growing and keep kicking ass
it's a trick
you're sucked up in a trick there's a
natural human tendency to accumulate
numbers for whatever reason go back to
our early days when resources were
scarce and if you get sucked into that
trick one day you're gonna wake up and
that that's gonna be usually be too late
you usually it's on your deathbed
usually it's close to it you like what
did I do this is it my health is failing
my life is falling apart and what has my
life been it's been 10 12 14 hours a day
in these stuffed offices under
fluorescent lights crunching numbers and
trying to acquire things and and for
what like what what impact have I made
on humans what would it what is the
negative impact of my ambition on the
people that around me like all this is
like the one thing that psilocybin and
particularly just psychedelics in
general can provide is a break from
patterns a stopping a cease fire of all
the momentum of our culture civilization
finances taxes credit-card debt all that
[ __ ] just stops and you get a chance to
step back and look at the Machine watch
it all whirl and spin in front of you
and you get to say oh I got sucked into
the trick I'm starting to attract
[Applause]